[Music]
hey this is Lee Greenway
Dave Ramsey 25 years from cut [ __ ]
congratulations on giving advice and
counsel to many people who read through
television in the radio broadcasting you
are the champion
congratulations on 25 successful years
in broadcasting well coming off a fourth
of July weekend having elite Greenwood
Congrats is appropriate we were actually
talking about Lee because you have to
talk about Lee on fourth of July of
weekend it's like a federal law right
because he has the song of all songs and
he's in his wife for good friends and I
catch a the guy's a genuinely nice guy
so he's just what you think you would be
what you hope he would be you know it
really is that guy you know we're
celebrating our 25 years old summer and
25 years here on the radio show the Dave
Ramsey show and its various forms and so
forth over all this time and one of the
things we did was we decided instead
doing just one day of celebration we
take a segment here or there and just
kind of reminisce now the next segment
you got to be ready for okay when we get
ready to do the next one we're going to
play we used to do this hour and we need
to do it again James because it was
hilarious called the stupid tax hour now
you know the saying I have that says if
you do something stupid with money and
you lose the money because you did
something stupid that's I call that
stupid tax now I've paid a lot of stupid
tax in my life and you probably paid
some in your life and we have people
call in and tell the dumbest thing they
had ever done to lose money and the
stories are freakin hilarious so we're
going to play some of those funny old
stupid tax stories the next time we do a
reminisce about the 25th anniversary
okay our about the 25 years aren't here
on the air so be listening the show be
watching for that because you don't
wanna miss the stupid tax hour but you
know one thing you guys didn't know was
that we also had a summer you didn't
know we had a Sunday night show for a
little while um I got this bright idea
because WSM radio was a home
by the same station wtn that I was on at
the time and was owned by Gaylord and
WSM am is where they broadcast the grand
ole opry now if you don't know anything
about radio which I didn't of course
when I started then a lot of people
don't know the basics of the electronic
side of the thing the the signal
delivery side of the thing on AM radio
the lower on the dial it is in other
words 557 20 those kind of 560 those
kinds of numbers on AM radio the less
power it takes to push the signal say 50
miles a hundred miles so a 5000 watt
station at 560 will outperform a 20,000
watt station up at the top end like 1720
or 1510 and that kind of thing right and
so if you can get a 50,000 watt a.m.
station low on the dial you have what's
known as a freaking blowtorch I mean
this thing will go for days
well WSM radio at night also has that CB
radio kind of effect where the signal
gets up on the atmosphere and skips
along because it's so powerful and so
650 a.m. 50,000 Watts at night covers 38
states and most nights Berto Rico so you
can hear the station from Nashville
Tennessee that plays old-time country
like old-time country not like
Australian singing country but like the
old twinkers right on that thing right
and so I mean it blasts out everywhere
so I got this bright idea that I needed
to do a radio show at night because it
would be in 38 states on there sounds
great doesn't it one station covers 38
states but I want to be on at night on
WSM AM well it's a week we contract with
the local with the Gaylord folks
I signed a one-year contract so they
take off the guy that's on there the
screaming preacher got is everybody
going to hell you know that AM radio
screaming preacher guy and they took him
off and put me on and I signed a
contract for a year
absolutely disaster y'all because
basically this is a em country radio and
it's it's not it's old-time country so
it's like Conway Twitty Johnny Cash
Porter Wagner this kind of stuff right
which I like my grandmother loved it and
apparently the average age listening was
my grandmother and so it was an absolute
disaster because my grandmother didn't
need to be out of debt
she had common sense she didn't want to
know all this stuff and so that age
group of people all across America are
going who is this guy on the radio
telling people get out of debt
I want to hear Conway Twitty you know
get this guy off it was awful we all I
mean we lost so much cuz I was paying
for it we don't usually pay for radio in
mainstream radio but I bought the time
because I was so convinced how great it
was going to be and oh he's lost so much
money the advertisers abandoned us
nobody was listening to it and I mean I
couldn't get my wife to listen to it it
was so bad and and the other thing other
people that listen on Sunday night are
drunk people
so these drunk people would call and
Blake Thompson would not figure out when
he was screening the calls that they
were drunk until they were on the air
and then we would get these bizarre
conversations going with some guy who's
been watching football all afternoon he
drank four six-packs of beer and then he
calls in on this radio show it was all
y'all it was the worst possible business
decision idea concept but it sounded so
good 38 states it's going to be a big
deal you know oh god I lost so much
money
it's unbelievable thank goodness I don't
borrow money I want to make a real mess
uh-huh so Wow
I think we lost like 78 grand I think by
the time we got out of it we had to talk
Gaylord they were kind and generous and
gracious they called the screaming
preacher guy he wanted back on he took
the slot back and they led us out of the
deal because it was just it was bleeding
money it was so bad but I you guys you
try stuff you know you try things to get
things to work we've tried a lot of
stuff on this show
the years to get things to work and we
started we used to drive over to
Opryland which is about a 40 minute
drive 35 minute drive from here from
where we all lived and had an office to
do the show because we used their studio
we didn't ever run a studio later on we
finally built our own first studio and
it was not soundproof so we had to put
up like construction yellow tape on that
end of the hallway of the office because
people would walk down the hallway
talking and you would hear them over the
air because the room wasn't soundproof
it was just it was just a little closet
that we turned into a studio and I'm
sitting in there and I bought a round
table that pressboard stuff you know
that sawdust kind of stuff that they put
Formica over like if it gets wet it
swells up you know that stuff right I
bought a table in the scratch and dent
corner of staples and I paid like four
dollars for the table because you not
going to see it it's on radio it wasn't
it wasn't open to the public like our
studio is now and we drilled holes in
that sawdust table and stuck the
microphone things down in it and had the
little arms with the microphone coming
out and over and had the caution tape up
for people to be quiet and Blake was in
one closet and I was in the other closet
we cut a hole between put up one piece
of Plexiglas we did not need an intercom
between the producer and the and the
radio host we could just talk through
the wall so you know if I was if we were
on a break we would just talk through
the wall because you could hear clearly
I mean it was like you ever been in a
bad cheap hotel you know exactly what
I'm talking about right that's what we
were doing it was just it was so but at
least we didn't have to drive and we
bought good microphones so the show
sounded good it's just if you were to
have visited that studio you would have
laughed and a little bored we were using
was about eighteen inches by 18 inches
now the one in here you can run a
spacecraft off of it but it's
unbelievable then we upgraded that
little bit paid cash upgraded a little
bit and paid cash this studio I guess I
probably got a million bucks in this
studio that we're sitting in now three
or four miles where the wires running
around me at this moment but you don't
start with that right and of course we
also had the southern accent going how
long is that clip I run out of time
yeah we'll play it another time because
I got to talking about the tell another
story I forgot but anyway yeah the
southern accent became a problem because
my son my southern accent still here
right you should have heard it back then
it was like Darrell in his other brother
Darrell didn't talk radio it was yeah
dubby dubby te and you were talking
Niceville I mean it was thick you guys
and so people in Boston thought we were
broadcasting from a trailer you know the
Yankees all thought we'd lost our mind
so I had to get a coach in to learn to
say ice instead ass and going instead of
going and I still say it sometimes when
I'm mad or get it get fired up but I've
gotten rid of enough of the southern
accent for credibility but I kept some
of it because it's part of my brand and
I'm proud of my southern heritage too so
there shut up more reminiscing later for
the 25th anniversary of the Dave Ramsey
show hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]